let me be clear the United Nations is
not leaving Sudan
our commitment is to the Sudanese people
in support of their wishes for a
peaceful and secure future we stand with
them at this terrible time
I've authorized the temporary location
both inside and outside Sudan of some
United Nations personnel
and of families
I call on all council members to exert
maximum leverage with the parties to end
the violence restore order and return to
the past of the democratic transition
we must all do everything within our
power to pull Sudan back from the edge
of the Abyss
Mr President
thank you for convening the security
Council today around the important issue
of effective multilateralism
multilateral cooperation is the Beating
Heart of the United Nations it's
resonator and guiding vision
the establishment of the United Nations
in 1945 represented Humanity's best
attempts to prevent any repetition of
the orders of two world wars and the
holocausts
over the past 78 years the multilateral
system has held together and delivered
some notable successes
the tools and mechanisms established by
the charter have played their part in
averting a third world war
peacemaking and preventive diplomacy by
the United Nations have helped end
conflicts around the world
United Nations peacekeeping operations
have helped societies move away from
conflict saving
perhaps millions of lives
our discernment and non-proliferation
efforts have helped to confine nuclear
weapons to a handful of states
and the United States Nations was
Central to the decolonization process
and Independence of 80 former colonies
today members of the U.N
we have helped to advance economic and
social progress and contributed to
reducing poverty and hunger eradicating
diseases and building recognition
respect for fundamental human rights
the global humanitarian system
coordinated by the United Nations saves
millions of lives each year
and multilateral solutions to Global
problems from the ozone layer to the
radication of polio are tried tested and
proven to work
none of this progress would have been
possible without countries standing
together as a multilateral human family
which makes today's situation all more
dangerous
we Face unprecedented and interlocking
crisis but the multilateral system is
under greater strain than at any time
since the creation of the United Nations
tensions between measured powers are at
an historic High
so are the risks of conflict through
misadventure or miscalculation
Russia's invasion of Ukraine in
violation of the United Nations
chartered international law is causing
massive suffering and Devastation to the
country and its people and adding to the
global economic dislocation triggered by
the covid-19 pandemic
elsewhere conflicts grind on from
Myanmar to the Sahel from Somalia to the
Democratic Republic of the Congo and
Beyond
the situation in Sudan now threatens to
destabilized the entire region
while there are some promising
developments in Yemen and Libya more
than 100 million people have fled their
homes to escape violence conflict and
persecution around the world
effective multilateral responses are
urgently needed to prevent and resolve
conflicts manage economic uncertainty
rescue the sustainable development goals
and address challenges to the global
Norms against the use and possession of
nuclear weapons